paraguay entra en alerta roja sanitaria
el gobierno decidió imponer la medida
luego de que el martes se registrará la
cifra más alta de contagios de toda la
pandemia con 2 mil 125 casos en un solo
día
paraguay se encuentra en estos momentos
en el nivel de alerta roja sanitaria
debido al aumento sostenido y récord de
contagios de koi 19 registrados en los
últimos días por lo que se ruega
encarecidamente a la población tener
conciencia y evitar situaciones que
puedan poner en riesgo la salud
individual y colectiva
y es que las autoridades sanitarias
señalan que las multitudinarias
protestas en contra del gobierno pueden
incrementar los contagios las
manifestaciones llevan cinco días
consecutivos y forzaron la salida de
cuatro ministros
en brasil la pandemia tampoco da 30 el
martes fue el día con más muertos por
coronavirus al contabilizar 1972
fallecimientos en 24 horas además la
agencia oficial fío cruz especializada
en tecnología de la salud también
advirtió un grave repunte de las
hospitalizaciones ante la situación
extremadamente crítica de las tasas de
ocupación de las camas de uci cobit que
indican sobrecarga e incluso colapso de
los sistemas de salud
los investigadores refuerzan el boletín
la necesidad de ampliar y fortalecer las
medidas no farmacológicas que involucran
la distancia física y social uso de
mascarillas e higiene de manos
en el país vecino argentina la principal
preocupación es por cuenta de la
variante brasileña el ministro de salud
de la provincia de buenos aires dijo que
el consejo nacional de salud discutirá
la posibilidad de restringir más la
frontera con brasil de aplicarse las
medidas podrían comenzar a partir del 12
de marzo